[Music]
you're cruising down the highway when
all of a sudden
endless rows of brake lights appear
ahead there's no
accident no stop light no change in
speed limit
or narrowing of the road so why the is
there so much traffic
when traffic comes to a near standstill
for no apparent reason
it's called a phantom traffic jam a
phantom traffic jam
is an emergent phenomenon whose behavior
takes on a life of its own
greater than the sum of its parts but in
spite of this
we can actually model these jams even
understand the principles that shape
them
and we're closer than you might think to
preventing this kind of traffic in the
future
for a phantom traffic jam to form there
must be
a lot of cars on the road that doesn't
mean there are necessarily
too many cars to pass through a stretch
of roadways smoothly
at least not if every driver maintains
the same consistent speed
and spacing from other drivers in this
dense but flowing traffic
it only takes a minor disturbance to set
off the chain of events
that causes a traffic jam say one driver
brakes slightly
each successive driver then brakes a
little more
strongly creating a wave of brake lights
that propagates backward through the
cars on the road
these stop-and-go waves can travel along
a highway
for miles with a low density of cars on
the road
traffic flows smoothly because small
disturbances like
individual cars changing lanes or
slowing down at a curve
are absorbed by other drivers
adjustments but once the number of cars
on the road exceeds a critical density
generally when cars are spaced less than
35 meters
apart the system's behavior changes
dramatically
it begins to display dynamic instability
meaning small disturbances are amplified
dynamic instability isn't unique to
phantom traffic jams
it's also responsible for raindrops sand
dunes cloud patterns and more
the instability is a positive feedback
loop
above the critical density any
additional vehicle
reduces the number of cars per second
passing through a given point on the
road
this in turn means it takes longer for a
local pileup
to move out of a section of the road
increasing vehicle density even more
which eventually adds up to stop and go
traffic
drivers tend not to realize they need to
brake far in advance of a traffic jam
which means they end up having to brake
harder to avoid a collision
this strengthens the wave of braking
from vehicle to vehicle
what's more drivers tend to accelerate
too rapidly
out of a slowdown meaning they try to
drive faster than the average flow of
traffic downstream of them
then they have to break again eventually
producing
another feedback loop that causes more
stop-and-go traffic
in both cases drivers make traffic worse
simply because they don't have a good
sense of the conditions ahead of them
self-driving cars equipped with data on
traffic conditions ahead
from connected vehicles or roadway
sensors
might be able to counteract phantom
traffic in real time
these vehicles would maintain a uniform
speed
safety permitting that matches the
average speed of the overall
flow preventing traffic waves from
forming
in situations where there's already a
traffic wave the automated vehicle
would be able to anticipate it breaking
sooner and more gradually than a human
driver
and reducing the strength of the wave
and it wouldn't take that many
self-driving cars
in a recent experiment one autonomous
vehicle for every 20 human drivers
was enough to dampen and prevent traffic
waves
traffic jams are not only a daily
annoyance they're a major cause of
fatalities
wasted resources and planet threatening
pollution
but new technology may help reduce these
patterns
rendering our roads safer our daily
commutes more efficient
and our air cleaner and the next time
you're stuck in traffic
it may help to remember that other
drivers aren't necessarily driving
spitefully but are simply unaware of
road conditions ahead
and drive accordingly
in a hurry but love physics we've got a
book wreck for you
astrophysics for people in a hurry is
fun accessible and may just blow your
mind
download a free audiobook version from
audible.com
ted dash ed and get lost in the stars